I personally always had a bit of an
affinity towards finding things that
unexpected so it find it incredible that
here in Dubai we do have this
world-class surfing community and we do
have waves you boys typically known for
high-rises and five-star luxury I think
this kind of bohemian underground surf
culture mixing with that is just a
pretty beautiful thing
[Music]
my name is Scott chambers and I'm the
founder and CEO of so fast Dubai I was
born in Sharjah in the UAE the UAE was a
very different place back then in the
90s and surfing culture was really
non-existent at the time over the last
25 years the surf community has grown
tremendously Dubai actually sits in the
ideal location to pick up the best rolls
that come through the Arabian Gulf
it just makes it a very favorable place
to learn how to surf
my friendship with fun started 20 years
back when we were in high school
together we shared the love for the
water and for surfing Scott and the
group to his friends were the first
surfers in Dubai a long time ago and I
saw the amount in the water and I wanted
to do what they were doing and I
remember paddling out for my first time
and catching that first wave and I was
totally hooked as Scott grew the surfing
community there was an opportunity for
me to come on board as a partner in the
business and I was to create this new
embassy for the surfing community to buy
in the United Arab Emirates is a is a
place that supports small businesses to
grow and for people to really create
really innovative concepts
the exhilaration and the connection with
the ocean is something that just can't
be described it promotes that ocean
culture that Ocean Minded consciousness
of our environment
surfing transcends cultures and
nationalities it's so amazing to see you
know Emiratis and non emery's both get
out in the water and have an absolutely
great time sharing the same experience
at the end of the day we're trying to
share this love for the sport and we do
teach Emiratis as well as eastern and
western expatriates and once you're in
there you never want to get out
[Music]